[Música]
bajo una creciente presión para
garantizar la seguridad de sus aliados
en afganistán el gobierno de bailén
reconoció que era necesario hacer más
por miles de personas que podrían pagar
un alto precio por sus vínculos con eeuu
el programa de visas de inmigrante
especial está definido cuidadosamente
por esta tutora y sabemos que hay
afganos que no califican pero que nos
ayudaron y merecen nuestra ayuda tenemos
una responsabilidad especial con estos
individuos ellos estuvieron con nosotros
nosotros estaremos con ellos el lunes el
departamento de estado dio a conocer sus
planes para ampliar el alcance de los
afganos que pueden obtener el estatuto
de refugiado en eeuu para incluir a las
personas que trabajaron para medios de
comunicación y agencias de ayuda con
sede en estados unidos pero también
empleados del gobierno y de la otan que
no cumplían los requisitos anteriores
hasta ahora sólo los contratados por el
gobierno de eeuu tenían derecho al asilo
los nuevos solicitantes tendrán que
salir de alta
están antes de poder iniciar el proceso
de un año de duración en un tercer país
una situación calificada de inaceptable
y por las ong exigir a los afganos en
riesgo que se conviertan primero en
desplazados internacionales antes de
solicitar visados pone aún más en
peligro al pueblo afgano que se ha
asociado con eeuu a medida que se
intensifican los combates los talibanes
toman varios puestos de control
fronterizos dejando a los refugiados
varados y sin poder salir del país según
estimaciones recientes hasta 100.000
afganos podrían acogerse al nuevo
programa de refugiados